so um benny let me ask you because like
i i've all your fans know some of black
soprano family right
i feel like there's a lot of people who
follow you
who exclusively um connect you with
griselda there's like generic hip-hop
fans who like obviously you're griselda
right
right right right so kind of tell us
what what
bsf is about and you know anytime i've
ever seen you i've seen
these guys with you right this is not
new this is and this is something you've
been
you know this is this has been your
imprint your
thing for a minute but kind of break
down the you know kind of the history of
bsf
uh basically man i started uh bsf
when i was in elmira correctional
facility reception you know i'm saying i
was
on my way to do a parole violation and i
just was ready for a change
from when i got back home so i started
in reception as soon as i got there
right we've been working me and rick you
know what i'm saying shout out to the
plates
played [ __ ] you know what i mean shout
out ricky not been doing this and i'm
saying even before all that you know i'm
saying he
from the hood so it's like when i came
home
it was like a resurgence of what we was
doing and uh i was taking everything way
more serious i was putting way more time
into it even i was going to
put a lot of time in it before it's like
i i felt that i needed i needed an extra
flame underneath so it was basically
like i remodeled the house and uh
rick you know i mean rick always been
right here since day one since he was
cause he was a younger since i was a
younger and it's crazy because he
he always been from the hub when he when
he was when he was serious about rapping
two years ago
he came and he paid me for a feature
right
you know i mean like that you know i
mean and that's when i was that's when i
was probably like getting a thousand
full verse but i'm like i only want to
take the money from him
this is my boy but i know what he wanted
he trying to get is he trying to get his
[ __ ] together but
after that i'm like nah man you just if
you're gonna do it you're gonna come
[ __ ] with us and do it you know i mean
so